hi my name is perch today I'll be
speaking about numeric array this is a
new container for storing numerical data
my name is Brenda care I work for Warfel
research and today I will tell you a
little bit about a new object that we
introduced in version 12 numeric array
which is a compact representation for
numeric arrays so I will start from
brief explanation why why do we even
need that what was the motivation behind
developing yet another array object and
then I will I will talk about the
construction and and conversion between
various types of numeric arrays next I
will show you some details how to use
numeric array in a lapper link and I
will finish with current integration of
numeric array in the world from language
and future paths
alright so briefly what what do we have
right now and why are we introducing a
new object so we we have sparse array
for a long time not a long time ago we
introduced structure all right
they are used for similar purposes that
is to store structured or a structured
sparse data so just just quickly to show
what what we gaining when it comes to
memory here oh so I'm creating the
sparse array that is not that small if
you look at the dimensions 256 by six
thousand 569 but it only takes three
thousand bytes to store that data
it spits because it's very sparse the
density level of that arises is very
small if we wanted to store it as a
dense dense list the byte count
obviously is much bigger so that way we
can reproduce basically very large
sparse data sets using spouse or
structural arrays
now byte array for storing raw bytes
one-dimensional stream of raw bytes that
is basically integers from 0 to 255 we
developed all right object that we call
byte array and again this is done as
efficient as possible so by default we
storing them in fact arrays so I'm
generating here the list of random
integers of length 1 million and then
well the byte count is is 8 millions
that's because these are 64-bit integers
so each one takes 8 bytes so that's
that's what we have well we can convert
that from data to byte array and you
already see that in the types I think it
just takes one mega byte so eight times
less memory so that's byte array and now
packed array it's well it's not really
talked about that but I guess everybody
knows that we have it we don't have
system functions for it but that's
that's why as you can see I'm using
developer context functions as the
utilities to to work with packed arrays
but well this is efficient container for
storing dance and there's numeric data
we support three types integer real and
complex 64-bit cyant integer right right
yeah it's all about yes it's 32 verse to
64 our somehow I really think that at
some point we drop that we do and go to
64 so yeah in integer real and complex
also basically three types
but we know that there are more than
that that there are more efficient types
for example by table I can store
integers from 0 to 255 efficiently so we
cannot have that as efficient to store
starting in a packed arrays
well but whatever we support in packed
Ric it is not as efficient as as
possible and many many built-in
functions generate packet arise for
example random integer does and that's
the function that we can test it really
is packed away we can actually unpack
that music another utility from the
developer context and if we unpack it
well it it is much worse when it comes
to memory all right so that's what we
had and what's missing
well we want to have a container that
can store all C++ fixed-width integer
types I there is a link here I'm not
going to go there but it's basically in
8 T you into a TT and and so on so
starting from one byte then 2 bytes four
bites and bites integers why they are
useful well many file formats actually
stores store the data in that way so if
you want to import the raw data
efficiently don't take more memory than
then need that that that's the container
we gonna use
so the I'm giving here the few examples
85 out your image or video files they
they all usually store the data as one
of this c++ fixed-width integer types
that is usually less than 64 bit
another reason we don't we didn't have
the container to store floating points
of single procedure basically floats or
the complex equivalent complex of cloud
float or complex of type float
now we can do it with numeric array as
well and finally this is something that
is hopefully coming but it's not there
yet we also want to support ha precision
floating point numbers that this is
called binary 16 either my Triple E
standard this is well not really not to
be supported by CPU but it is thought to
be supported on for GPO and and and it's
useful for for GPO computations you
could a neural net was training dots
that's where you get the speed using
high precision floating point numbers
all right so numeric array that's how
the syntax looks like we basically have
three different arguments it were three
three three at three different arguments
so let's start from this middle case
which is I think that it's going to be
most useful and for version 12 we
support 12 types of numeric arrays and
he lit a list so as you can see all the
fixed-width integer types are already
supported float and complex of float is
also supported and real 32 is basically
equivalent of C++ float and complex 64
is basically complex of float and we
also support the types that are
supported in fact arrays well except
mink which is platform dependent here is
everything is kind of platform
independent so that is complex 128 is
equivalent to packet array a complex
type really 64 is basically double
precision floating point number
all right so how to create thematic
array well give it a list and specify
the type and that's that's it this is
our type set ago you saw that
typesetting before that that's our
summary box so but what you can use be
access here you already see the type the
dimensions and also the list of the
first few elements okay so there is no
specific other functions developed to do
the conversion between numeric array
types that so we have the constructor
and converter implemented in a single
function and you may be familiar with
that concept we already have that
concept in image or audio objects we use
constructor and converter in a single
function well so to convert it you just
pass the first argument to numeric array
is already existing numeric array and
and then you specify the output type you
want so that was two argument syntax now
quickly about one argument syntax well
we don't specify the type in in this
case we just pass it at all right so we
try to guess what we have
heuristics what what would be the most
compact representation of the data you
you're passing through two numeric
arrays so for example here there are
numbers from 1 to 5
we decided that unsigned integer 8 is
the best type here
it could be scientifically it for this
one but not really losing or gaining
anything as long as they are all
positive we can we can go to two
unsigned integer okay this is basically
repetition of what I'd already said
numeric arrays require less memory than
packed arrays most of the time so packed
arrays
eight million bytes and then converting
that to numerically we get eight times
less the molecular constructor also
takes different arise and I can convert
them to do numeric array so for example
sparse array can be easily converted to
numeric array simple structure try we
can also very efficiently convert
between byte array and numeric array
this is as efficient as possible in a
sense that if we can we don't even do
any memory copy we just replaced a head
the reason is that byte array and
numeric array are underneath the same
data structure this is basically a
different head so you can think about
numeric 1d numeric array of type
unsigned integer eight as a byte array
with just different type and that's why
if the rep count is easy of the
expression is equal to one there is just
a fat replace as fast as possible and
same is true if you convert byte array
so this is again new new behavior for
the byte array constructor you can now
give it a numeric array and it will just
generate byte array as long as this this
to Marik array is one D and is of the
given type of the unsigned integer 8
otherwise it will fight ok the last
syntax we also introduced the coercion
method here or actually yeah Kershaw
argument that can take four different
values in version 12 the default value
is clip and round and what it does it
clips the specified range and rounds
reels to integers so here is an example
so I have minus 1 to point 2 & 3 but I
want that constructor to convert or
change that value to feed the unsigned
integer 8 and that's what happens my
minus 1 is converted to
or flip to 0 and then 2.0 is converted
to 2 and we we get unsigned integer 8
numerically another method we call it
clip it only Clips the specified to the
specified range so in this case -1 is
changed to 0 but say I want to do this
with with a clip Matata it's going to
fail because clip does not run non
integers that in here we have the
floating-point numbers to interior so
this method will fail for this input
round as the name says it only rounds so
it doesn't clip which means that now I
have minus 1 here and it's not working
because it's not it's not going clip and
finally yep
wait the clip ok you want to go to back
to clip and 2.0 that's not failing why
why would that fight it with not losing
every procedure so yes I it's it smart
enough to well ok I should prep the
motion it's it's all the pages are
marked experimental if you think it's
something is not what you think it how
should it ok let me know they stood at
the better but that that's the way it
behaves right now check well it checks
if if all the values are are compatible
if something is not right it's gonna
fail so here for example two point two
is not going to be rounded if I had
minus one it would also play so these
are the four equation methods we
introduced all right
not much time left so let me go quickly
here there are in tears an integration
of this new object numeric array in the
library link so you basically can use
now what numeric array you can
efficiently pass numeric arrays and byte
arrays to and from your library function
at the C C++ and of of library like this
objects appear as m numeric array but m
numeric array as if you are familiar
with M tensor or M sparse alright M
image they are very similar this is
basically a pointer to a data structure
that is passed by reference so how are
we doing this for if you specify the
your library function you can pass the
Barrick array by specifying library data
type of numeric array or liability a
type of byte array for for 4 byte array
but we can do more we can actually do
the memory management for those who
really want to get as as efficient
passing as possible we we allow you to
pass a reference don't do the copy by
default we make a copy so it's it's very
safe and we we take care of the memory
management so that that copy is is going
to be garbage collected but there are
other memory management that there is a
derelict a set for memory management you
can you can do the constant passuk and
in that case we actually passing
reference and that means you should not
modify the values that you get either
C++ otherwise its it can basically crash
or many bad things may happen if you do
it but on the other hand you say big
memory you know
you can you can sign up copy every time
you passing their numeric array on vital
rato
to the C++ code exactly the same thing
the same memory management is for byte
array so that was for input arguments
the output is well we have only two
types either automatic or shared for how
would you use it well we have a new
header file distributed in Mathematica
12 layout which is called wall from
numerical I ever library detach that's
how it looks like so first the basically
supported types that correspond to the C
type then we have conversion method
there are more methods here than I
described but I don't have time to go
over the days but and finally the list
of functions that are supported again
whoever is familiar with what what we
have for tensors this is very very
similar so so should be very easy to use
the one new functionality is the convert
type function that allows you to
basically convert between data types of
numeric arrays so quickly given that
header file I have a first America right
demo what I implemented here is the
reverse of 1d numeric array that's as
the code that the notebook is already
uploaded so I'm not gonna go over the
details the code well great library
generated at the DLL for being and here
is my function that as you can see the
input argument is numeric array I'm
passing it using the constant passing
and returning is also numeric array so
let's create a numeric array and used
that function so that's that input
America right takes the numbers from 1
to 5
and I get it in regards as the output
byte array demo so I get very similar
what what when it comes to the C++ first
include the header files are all
necessary in Chinese Asian I mean sure
is Asian and so on well what what's
happening for for beta right I'm
basically reading bro bytes from a file
and then store it it in byte array and
create library create a function and
apply that function on a gif image we
have a rose dot gif file in the layout
so I'm passing it a file path to that
function and it returns the byte array
and actually I can show you that this
works correctly by importing that byte
array but basically the same if you just
call import on on that file under people
okay so that's that's the last slide
what what's already working and what's
not working in 12 functions that accept
numeric arrays so first of all numeric
array as as you could guess is basically
atomic object so atom curators throw on
a numeric array or byte array but for
now riq returns false I really hope this
is going to change or it should change
but we're not ready for it in in 12 4.0
if you wanna get the packed array or in
some cases it's not going to be packed
array it's going to be just list of
numbers you can use normal so normal on
the open America right gives you a list
back usually it's packed
but yes in this case but for cases like
2 to the power 64 minus 1 we cannot
store such number in a packed array so
notice that what I returned is not
packed it is just a expression other
functions that work with numeric array
so fractures like length equal first
most min max work other category of
functions extracting the elements apart
take drop also supported in version 12
however this is a one limitation that
you should be aware of the rare signing
apart doesn't work doesn't work today
that doesn't really mean that it way we
may still have the support 1812 if not
indefinitely 12.1 it will be supported
other functionalities that already use
numeric array in version 12
import/export for example fits but
import and export allow you to to either
in get or or store it in the fits file
numerical is saying for hdf5 neural
networks become dates coming in version
12 for Merrill networks net decoder and
net encoder will accept and will return
numeric arrays and this will give you
around speed-up of 2 for some kinds of
nothing coders and I should mention that
we also have a new compiler cavity in in
version 12 and the gnu compiler supports
all the types that are supported in for
ford america right it's just not
integrated yet enough so that we we we
will do it again we will integrate it
for
hopefully very soon maybe it may be like
next release
so future versions as I mention at the
beginning half precision floating point
number we definitely want to add a
arithmetic and statistic of operations
on numerical is numeric arrays then
obviously functional programming
constructs like map and scan and and
more import export formats you should
also start accepting and returning
numeric arrays so these are our plans
that for version 12 and we really hope
that version 13 will have the full
support for all all from language
functions that operate on lists thank
you like arithmetic operations on
numeric array well it's it's complicated
and you have to think about the
equations between the types right you
have the integer 8 plate and then
integer outside edj 16 right what would
you do I mean we this is this work was
really needed to implement a new
compiler so we kind of have it it's not
we need that extra layer to integrate it
with with numeric arrays but we have
help out of these type questions that at
how it should all behave on on
arithmetic operations well right we have
to have these heuristics we have to have
your automatic behavior we obviously
want it maybe you wanna do that manual
acquires the to the common type and then
do that arithmetic on the common type
then but all we have to do that interval
anyway right but we have to make some
assumptions right given two different
integer types we have to decide what
what the return
our what if you divide right but if you
divided by another one we cannot store
rational numbers and we don't have all
of this figure out yet up to the very
end whether we fail or somehow convert
both of these arise due to floating
points right or floating point I guess
these are two options not a number a not
yet but hopefully at some point we will
support well I think all parts in taxes
are supported except the reassigning the
part that does it work but well I if
it's possible to return America right we
want to return America right but it's
the same question right if you do that
sign or on an integer in America right
well what exactly would you expect would
you expect actually a list of symbols or
would you expect a numeric array of
floating points and we lose the
precision we go from infinity to the
machine precision right
okay if no more questions then thank you
[Applause]